our next guests are the talented women
behind the critically acclaimed aretha
franklin biopic movie it's called what
else respect
she's an oscar winner she's a grammy
winner she's a badass she is jennifer
hudson she plays aretha franklin she's
also an executive producer on the film
dropped the microphone she was
hand-picked for this part by the queen
of soul herself before she died in 2018.
respect tells the story behind aretha
franklin's greatest hits and the legacy
that she left behind now jennifer
performed aretha songs live for the film
including her iconic performance at
madison square garden in 1968 here's a
look
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i said does she sound good we're joined
now by jennifer hudson and the film's
director that's liesel tommy this is
liesel's by the way her first movie film
so go you liesel tommy jennifer let's
start with you listen i've been
following you been smitten with you
since american idol since back that's
how long that i've been following
jennifer hudson but i think it's
interesting the choice i've heard you
say that you made
about singing arethas you said i wasn't
going to imitate aretha i was going to
be me
how did you make the how did you do that
um what was your process in nailing it
that way
i think it came down to because that was
one of the main things that i said with
like okay how am i supposed to approach
this vocally yeah but it ended up being
at least in my mind allowing her musical
influence that she's had on me to come
through while using her approaches um
her technique uh where she sings from
like tom jones that daleko said she
sings from the top of her head and i
said well where do i sing from he's like
well you sing from your feet you know
what i'm like okay now what does that
mean you know so blending those worlds
together and then
i feel like i come through the most when
the emotions kick in yes i needed to be
like okay that's where i need to come in
to be able to emote the emotion and help
tell the story this is a casting move
that in in my view just has always made
just too much sense the first time i
ever saw you saying i was like if anyone
can play aretha it's it's jennifer yeah
but it's gotta come with a lot of
intimidation in some ways
yes definitely like it's exciting well
it also was my dream to play her as well
but then it's like okay this is exciting
but then it's the scariest thing it's
the queen of soul yeah you know me and
it's someone we all treasure and love
you know at least for all of us we were
like okay we know what we're dealing
with you're saying an aretha franklin
song in uh american idol that was my
audition song that was her introduction
to america
right yeah
lisa your first movie is aretha
franklin's love wow i know i mean it was
there were definitely times when i woke
up in the middle of the night and i said
to myself what the heck are you thinking
yeah but you know you knew you could do
it from the moment i got the call that
they were interested i knew what the
film should be i knew what it should
look like i knew the music i knew what
time period it should be and i just told
them you know when it was supposed to be
just a casual chat and i was like no
this is what it is
prepared so lisa what one of aretha
franklin's biographers said that denial
was a strategy for her to survive
emotionally but denial is not a good
strategy for storytelling so how did you
decide what of her life which was a
difficult and complicated life what to
leave in and what to leave out well i
wanted to to focus the film on the time
before she became the aretha franklin we
all know
the the the birth of a diva kind of like
a superhero you know creation film um
because that's how i viewed her like she
was a superhero
and so the the things the struggles the
traumas of her childhood created who she
was as an adult and i wanted us to see
what all goes into making somebody like
aretha franklin yeah jennifer i've heard
you say that you probably couldn't have
played this role if you hadn't gone
through talking about traumas you hadn't
gone through some of the experience and
traumas that you've had
how did that help you in playing this
role
um
by like in being in the middle of scenes
and realizing it in that moment like wow
uh i feel as though she saw so much more
in me where we kind of paralleled than i
did you know and it wasn't until i was
literally in the middle of certain
scenes so i'm like wow especially the
scene when her mother comes to her yes
at times i'm like
it's like it felt real to me i know i
thought about you and your mother i
remember your mom and how proud she was
of you i was wondering when you were
playing that scene yeah
yeah that was really close to that yeah
you talked about aretha's influence
you're you're both singers that came out
of the church yes sir what was aretha's
influence on you oh my god even there
like i didn't realize even to the film
how much of an impact she was in my life
unconsciously so until doing research
for the film and
searching deeper in her music say for
example like amazing grace or even
precious memories um all the hymns i
grew up singing in church was structured
by her amazing grace album that i didn't
realize and so i'm like wait a minute so
we got that from aretha you know so i
was always up under it unconsciously and
you became friends you guys became
friends and had a relationship with each
other what did you talk about with her
um we would talk weekly
and again i always say i feel like she
taught me more about life while teaching
me about her life but i don't i didn't
realize how much she was speaking from
experience yeah
until
while we were in the middle of you know
creating the film we did talk about my
baby a lot yeah because she was a cook
and she loved eating i talked the last
time i spoke to her was august 8th oh
right before right and i was like she
called me like wow
and on that call she sang she sang she
did what did she say i see brothers i
can't remember the song she said that's
the isaac brothers jennifer i said yes
ma'am i know
and then she had told me what she had
eaten and it was as if she could taste
it right there on the phone
and then she asked about little david
because he loves to cook yeah and he
does oh he can cook oh that's cool i'm
having to make you a cake oh i would
like it okay
icing is my happy place lisa i've heard
you say that you wanted the queen of
soul that you approached it with the
queen of soul that you wanted that to
have a particular meaning yeah when i
was when i was thinking about the script
with tracy scott wilson the writer i
thought to myself what is
the queen of soul mean what is it what
is soul and what does it mean to be the
queen of it
and how does that impact our
storytelling you know and so i really
analyzed that and what i kind of came to
understand is
you know that's why when i pitched the
my idea for the film it should begin in
the church and end in the church and
that the the the amazing grace album the
the one that the album that she was so
successful with that was her best
selling i think it would be like our
triumphant moment in the film because
it's when she kind of came back to her
roots yeah and i always think that
that's such a compelling journey um you
know for for somebody to to begin
somewhere um get drawn away and then
find their their such an interesting
part of aretha's story because because
she came up through the church
and a lot of at that time
singers weren't we're leaving gospel
they that was considered you didn't go
to pop you know sam cook kind of broke
the mold there and she kind of followed
him yes exactly and there were
definitely people in in their circle
that you know had questions about her
deciding to leave you know gospel but as
she would say she never left gospel she
never left the church it was inside of
her even when she was making her pop in
r b albums always jennifer they're
they're already talking oscar buzz for
you don't be scared but they're already
talking about the oscar buzz aretha was
talking oscar buzz right away you better
win an oscar for this that's the very
first thing she said i said oh lord okay
and in new york we can see you saturday
you're on stage at central park i am i
can't wait i'm super excited to perform
for audience but first i get to do
apollo so come on out and see that as
well
thursday night yes all right jennifer
hudson liesel congratulations to you
both thank you thank to be here thank
you respect is coming out in theaters
right now go to where you like to go and
wear your mask